it's bella's birthday and she's having
the dream all teenage girls have where
their old grandmas while their vampire
boyfriend is still young that's gross
while opening gifts clumsy bella cuts
herself which causes jasper that see
bella as a hamburger oh no wrong film he
actually just attacks her the next day
edward tells bella he is moving away and
leaves her in the dust this is the last
time you'll ever see me bella takes this
well moping in her room for months while
the seasons change outside she soon
finds herself a new man in jacob who
turns out to be a shape-shifting wolf
still not good enough for bella though
who jumps off a cliff she has been
hearing edward's voice since he left and
she's able to hear him again after doing
this this is dangerous she was rescued
by jacob but edward thinks she is dead
he goes to italy to have a beautiful
destination death at the hands of the
voltori but they refuse he makes the
only logical decision and goes to get
naked and sparkle in front of a crowd of
people but bella stops him in slow
motion now facing the voltori bella's
life is spared on the condition that she
is turned into a vampire eventually they
move back the forks and edward bribes
bella to marry him i have one condition
marry me